hi there and welcome back my dear
fellow scholars today we're going to
look at multi-modal neurons in
artificial neural networks
by gabrielle go nick camarada chelsea
vos
shan carter michael petrov ludwig
schubert
alec radford and chris ola that has
appeared in this
distil pop journal which i think is a
pretty cool journal
going beyond the classic pdf publishing
so this paper is an investigation
into the new clip model by open ai
and specifically the discovery of what
they call multi-modal
neurons in this model so this is an
investigative work they work with
visualizations and i've made a video
about both the
clip model as well as the feature
visualizations
that has appeared previously so
safe to say what they are claiming as
the high-level claim here is that in
biology
we sort of expect there to be neurons
that respond
not to individual patterns or to
individual words
but to concepts so there could be a
concept neuron
of halle berry as you can see here and
that neuron would respond
to photographs of halibury to drawings
and sketches of halle berry
and also to text so if we see the text
the rasterized text or we hear the word
that neuron that same neuron would fire
now so far
in artificial neural networks
we had not seen this kind of multimodal
perception
so we have seen neurons responding in
general to the same class
of images because we train them as image
classifiers
but we have not seen that generalized to
other modalities such as drawings or
text
what they find in this clip model right
here is that
exactly what we expect in humans or
in general in biological neural networks
that happens so they find for example a
neuron
that responds to spider-man that is you
know
photos of spider-man in the real world
or
some person in a spider-man costume
uh drawings of spider-man and also
text that says spider so that would
always
the neuron would respond to all of these
things the same neuron
and that is a sort of sign
that these models have learned to
connect different modalities
together we've already discussed in the
clip video
that the
the model sort of learns to do ocr
so it learns to recognize text because
the clip model is
fundamentally a model that connects
images to
text and my claim here
is going to be that this addition of
text the model i think is very much a
text model
so a lot of the connection it makes go
via the textual level
and a lot of the responses you're going
to see here the visualizations
are going to deal with text rather than
with images so here you can see what
this neuron responds to
if you thought it was the spider web
here no there is
spider as a text spider here spider
there
drawings of spiderman so this neuron
would respond to all of these things
which is pretty pretty cool so
what they do what they present here is
an overview
over the different neurons they find and
as i understand it what they
have done is they've gone through these
neurons and they use their feature
visualization technique with every
single one of them
so i can show you what that looks like
here is the this is the open ai
microscope and you can find that and
this is the exact model they're looking
at
so what you can do is you can simply
click
around in these neurons over here
and then these are the visualizations
right here so now the visualizations are
twofold so on the left hand you have
channel optimization on the right hand
you have neuron optimization
we've treated them in a previous video
if you want to know how they come about
but for now what you should know is that
these are images
that activate that particular neuron or
that particular channel
very much so they these images activate
this particular thing in the neural
network but
not other things so this is a way to see
what these neurons respond to heavily
so here you can see on the left you
often have kind of patternish structures
on the right do you more have kind of
in the center individual
things so maybe it's not really clear
what this is
so what they also portray is data
samples from the imagenet dataset that
activate
mostly that particular neuron so
you can pretty clearly see that this
responds to popsicle
ice cream now they also have a different
data set down here there is a flicker
creative commons and very much same you
see this is kind of ice and ice cream
and at the bottom you have text
that goes along with it so here it's not
really
ice cream so this is a bit of a failure
case
but you always have to keep in mind that
it could also be because of the
lack in power in searching for text so
what they do down here is they
have a search algorithm that finds
pieces of
text that that neuron responds to highly
so text that maximizes the dot
product so in the clip model you have an
image part
you have a text part and you have a dot
product at the end
so this is text that when you input it
to the text part
maximizes the dot product with that
particular
neuron so it's not always going to be
you know really
good text but very often you can give
you a hint in what the neuron thinks
note that this isn't the same text as
we're going to see
later like the text that you saw in
spider-man
because the text you saw in spider-man
that was rendered text so they do a lot
of investigation into render text
because the clip model is quite good
at responding to rendered text in the
image side
all right so they find they look at
these neurons
literally i think they just click here
on the left boom and you look at them
so this seems to be like a hamburger
pancake neuron
and it is i i did this for hours and
i'll show you later what i found
this is absolutely fascinating what
you'll find here by just clicking
through
and every now and then you find
something like yeah
all right but let's get back to the
paper first
so the paper they find
region neurons so neurons that respond
to different
regions of the world for example the usa
now they not only do they have um
not only do they have this visualization
technique
for a for kind of the whole image they
have
faceted visualization so in this paper
they introduce
faceted visualization which they can so
they can
produce specifically faces
that are u.s that respond to
usa they can produce specifically
indoor things so this is all the same
neuron
these are images that are made such that
they represent
indoor scenes and there is an appendix
if you want to know how that's done
they can trim it to only produce nature
pictures that
this particular neuron responds to so
here you can get a much better insight
into
what into what the neuron looks at for
example
in if you create faces for the usa this
is
i don't know i call this one i call this
one benjamin washington
uh because it's a sort of a blend of ben
franklin and george washington
but in general it's pretty cool so you
can even
yeah nature you can do pose for north
america
uh pose for the u.s i think that's kind
of a gi
a pose for europe i don't know what that
is
but it doesn't always you know work out
super well
but they find person neurons so neurons
that respond
to individual people be that
faces be that text so
this is donald trump be that poses
yeah um elvis
is also pretty cool i've actually found
i don't know if it i found
the elvis neuron myself or if i found a
different one
yeah so they also have emotion
neurons which is also pretty cool where
they so they find the neurons that
respond to
particular emotions so when they tell
these neurons when they make
a faceted reconstruction and
tell please give me a face this is what
comes out
and that you know is just shocking when
you do
something like a pose um for shocked
this i think we're only scratching the
surface here
um honestly but
you you can see the claim here the claim
is that
the same neuron responds to this
picture and to this picture this is
supposed to be text uh you can only
guide it you can't you know force it
to this picture indoor to this picture
uh so the same neuron will respond to
all of these
and they call that multimodal neuron
because it represents a concept
the concept of being shocked rather than
in a particular fine-grained pattern
which was always the kind of problem so
far
with these neural networks that the they
were
more looking at you know low-level
patterns than
high level concepts it seems with
clip with by combining modalities like
images and text and by not forcing this
constraint
like in a classifier into 1 000
pre-defined classes we can gain
much more we can go up the hierarchy of
features so they have art style they
have holiday neurons religion neurons
person trait neurons
abstract concept neurons the star i
found the star
i yeah i remember time neurons counting
neurons
pairs of force they are not always so
super good
but it clearly goes into the good
direction so here they highlight
specific
things first person neurons so they find
neurons that respond for example to
jesus christ
so they would respond to all of these
images here on the right you see their
crosses jesus christ and so on
depictions of jesus drawings of jesus
and when you ask the model to generate
you
a image that reconstructs this neuron's
activation
and you can force it or you guide it to
make a face
this turns out if you got it to make a
pose
this turns out um
a logo obviously they also have
hitler right here which is also pretty
cool though i have if you click on these
things you'll get
actually to the microscope thing and
this is the one for for hitler and
you know i'm i'm not entirely sure
that this is the case like i can see you
know the kind of mustachy thing but if
you look at
what in the data set activates this one
it's it is a bunch of swastikas but it
is also just a bunch of kind of german
political
stuff um
but yeah i mean the concept the concept
here even if it's not hitler directly
is pretty pretty cool uh i yeah
also found that domain endings
rendered as images will activate
the same neuron as the flag
of that country and activate the same
neuron as like the architecture of that
country it is
super duper interesting all right so
they have these person
neurons which is already cool and they
have so they've found these they do a
case study here
for the donald trump neuron so the
donald trump
neuron recognizes donald trump and then
they want to see
what images in the data set activate
this neuron
by how much so they make the claim here
that if you for example choose profile
pictures of donald trump
you see here is the zero line and here
is the standard deviations from zero
activation so
pictures of donald trump activate this
neuron like 30 times more
than it is activated over the whole data
set
which makes sense if that neuron
responds to donald trump but it also
responds to
art images containing donald trump by
the way these are classified by the
authors here they've gone through the
images
and they've classified them into these
categories
text containing donald uh trump's name
the model also strongly responds with
the same neuron
right that's the that's the crazy part
so a picture
with text in it that says
trump activates the same neuron as a
profile picture
of trump activates the same neuron as a
maga hat and activates sometimes the
same neurons political images
uh activates so the
if you look at games and music and so on
that is very that neuron is very
deactivated so not only is it
zero it's actually negative which the
authors
interpreted as sort of being being
counter to that in the space of all
concepts
um they do so this paper is
is full of this kind of content warnings
it might be disturbing and so on
which you know you can you can do but i
also find
i also find the rest of the paper is
kind of a
fairly large hedge against certain
things and it gets political
at times for example when they want to
when they want to claim that um
so here on the other hand it most
negatively activates
to musicians like nicki minaj and eminem
video games like fortnite
civil right activists like martin luther
king jr and lgbt symbols like
rainbow flags so the games and the
fortnite here
yes we can see that but if you click on
this and they have four
images of this you can see that it's
activated at
relatively low magnet like negative
magnitudes which is correct but then it
is also
almost equally activated over here at
high magnitudes so like
i see the point you're trying to make
but i mean if
if you are in the political sphere this
is not
you have to you have to not interpret
this as
meaning that these things are kind of
aligned
but you have to interpret it as
these things will appear together often
which you know one can one can
definitely
understand in this case so here
they search for profile pictures of
other people
including donald trump himself and they
plot how much these profile pictures of
other people activate
the trump neuron and you can see that
for example um
well yeah pence activates this neuron
by quite a bit i i think yeah the
selection here
is you know up to the authors of course
but it's it's fairly interesting to see
that um clinton
cruz and obama activated more than
hitler uh and almost as much as steve
jobs for some reason um
so i'm not i'm not entirely sure
what you can make of this but it's
definitely interesting
to in on this side like to observe the
multi-modality of pictures
just the fact that texts drawings
symbols of that campaign
and profile pictures will all activate
the same neuron that is
fairly impressive they go on and they
identify
emotion neurons so again there's a
content warning by the way also here
so here they identify a neuron that
responds to surprise or shock and you
can see
that all of these pictures on the right
will activate that
neuron so there are faces being shocked
there are horses being shocked
and there is rendered text saying like
wtf omg
and so on again if you i think we've
we've gone through this this is the the
shocked one
um there there are also secondary
neurons
that help let's say help um
the primary emotion neurons so
here you can see an overview over the
different
emotion neurons they have found and it
is
pretty stunning so here they ask them
obviously to
um create a face when they constrain
them
not constrain they guide them towards
making poses by the way the way you
guide them is they train
linear probe classifiers on separate
data sets so they would
train a classifier on a face data set
to distinguish all faces from all
non-faces
and then that use that classifier to
sort of guide this reconstruction
process
that's how you can sort of choose to end
up with a face
or with a pose or with a piece of text
so
as you can see it's pretty pretty
cool that even the text that comes out
of this reconstruction process these
aren't real images right these are kind
of
reconstructed to activate those neurons
like for
evil you can see that there's devil and
satan
uh for shocked it's like omg
uh for crop for happy it's
it's happy if you look at the poses
for happy for serious evil
is particularly cool um
incarcerated rejected this is
i think this is absolutely cool there is
the nsfw there is erotic there
are erotic neurons and
if i click on this it will show now
if you click on this absolutely nothing
not safe for work
will happen i i promise uh i don't
promise
but you know i i i've tried it
it's fine i will not click on it because
if this model thinks that's
not safe or work the youtube algorithm
will think is not safe for work
so but what i can tell you is that if
you go
on that neuron and you go click through
it to go to the microscope
and you look at what image net pictures
respond to that neuron heavily you'll
find out that imagenet
isn't the um really clean
dog breed data set that you might have
known all right they
found other neurons corresponding to
silly facial expressions like uh duck
faces
and and and tongue showing and so on
which is
is pretty neat and they find
this neuron that corresponds to mental
illness which
their reconstruction is just amazing
like this is just
mind baffling um nature kind of always
looks the same
but mental illness let's say
face this is it's crazy
uh how this model connects things and it
connects these things
to uh books and
writings of sad mental health anxiety
and so on now do i think
the model understands what a mental
illness is no
i don't think so i think much like in
gpt 3
it is learned to statistically associate
things so it has learned that there
might be
and i think that happens via the textual
input so
in clip for every image you have a piece
of text
and i think the connection between the
topics happens on the textual level
because the text descriptions are the
same
between images so there are the images
of people
you know cowering like this being sad
and the textual description for it would
be something like mental illness
anxiety sadness and then for these
pictures of these books as well there
the descriptions would be i mean this is
what's literally called overcoming
anxiety so if the picture is of a book
and
the description says what is on the
picture
obviously that text will be connected so
i think that's how it learns
to connect things via the text and i
think this
thing is in large part a text model
so here they do the same study for
images that are associated with
mental illness um so
depression sad pictures like anxiety
pictures
are pretty high depressing jokes
if you look at music and sports that's
negatively activated
and so on so you can see that i think
via the text
the model can sort of learn about how
different
different concepts different things
different patterns
are connected to one another they have
region neurons
which i find pretty cool so they
discover neurons
when they show them a crop of this world
map
this this world map when they show them
a crop of the world map
the the neuron will respond the neural
will
flare up and so the neuron
this red neuron here that
reacts to these pieces of text and now
it reacts
to the pieces of text when they are
rendered into images right then the
neuron responds
if you render the word american
in an image and then you give it to the
network that neuron will flare up
this same neuron will flare up if you
show it
a crop of this region here of the map
which is crazy like crazy
again i think the connection happens um
in the textual domain but still crazy
you can have it do face facets for these
different
regions um yeah if you if you go over
here
so the neuron that responds to this blue
area responds to the rendered words
mumbai singh pakistan
afghanistan bangladesh and responds
strongly or if you make reconstructions
that activate that neuron you get these
kinds of
pictures which you know is fairly cool
the same here
for europe so this is kind of european
and yeah i
that looks like home um
so check this out a bit for yourself but
it's
immensely cool they even find these
secondary
regional neurons that aren't exactly
regional
but they also respond to crops of this
map and they highlight this entrepreneur
neuron that you know it it responds to
sort of the words entrepreneur
entrepreneurial
and it you know it kind of looks like
his company logos a little bit
i guess but it you know the the model
that responds to the word
entrepreneur lights up when you
show it the west coast of the us kind of
the
um the california region
interestingly it also lights up when you
show it the
west coast of the of the lower of the
southern african continent which
is cool like that's definitely
unexpected
i don't know i i'm not informed enough
to know whether or not there is
significant
um entrepreneurial drive going on there
could also be that it the model simply
confuses the west coast of the two
countries
right like they look in a crop they look
the same
could be i'm not i'm not i don't know
so maybe i'm wrong um it's also
interesting that only these regions
light up
right if for this particular neuron
uh so i have my doubts whether that's
just kind of a
a lucky cherry pick i'm not saying it's
cherry picked but you know kind of like
you stumble upon and you make something
of it or not
they have more case study of african
kind of sub
divisions and
let's go down here here is where they
discuss that they can also produce text
for the text side of clip so not only do
they render and
this this text here is what you're going
to see
um the maximal text aligned with an
image or with a neuron sorry
is what you're going to see at the
bottom of the microscope pages
so lastly they
force a they kind of make a sparse code
out of their
main neurons that they find and they
try to build more complex emotions from
them for example
jealous and they do
they do claim here that that makes sort
of a bit of sense
like jealous is champion
plus hug plus grumpy minus crying
um i'm not exactly sure
if you know if that makes super much
sense so board is relaxing plus grumpy
maybe yeah
intimate is soft smile plus heart minus
sick you can you can probably make
something out of that
though yeah powerful
is lightning miracle plus evil
plus yoga that's that's definitely
definitely the case
do check it out um it is
very interesting to look at some of
those things even though i think
it does not make you know
terrible much sense but uh in
often cases but stressed being success
plus mental disorder
plus pink objects maybe
but it is more kind of it is not claimed
that this is you know kind of an
absolute thing it's more
an investigation into these networks if
you lay them out
in sort of a 2d surface you can see that
uh these emotion neurons they
come pretty close to sort of an atlas
uh of what people when we just use two
factors we roughly reconstruct the
canonical mood axis of in much used in
much of
psychology valence and arousal so
you can divide these emotions into two
things
so there is valence which is good or bad
so i think that's top
bottom here so here's mad angry hostile
and so on
maybe not um
[Music]
no top bottom is probably valence like
how strong
something is and then left right might
be good and bad no
also not here insecure inspired aroused
awful sad well these are all bad no
hostile is here
appalled is here and horrified is here
where are you happy in the middle maybe
creative
okay happy is here
um also it might not be exactly axis
aligned right
you can also divide it into seven
factors which
we nearly reconstruct a well-known
categorization of these emotions
into happy surprised bad disgusted
fearful
and angry except with disgusted switch
for a new category
related to affection that includes
valued loving lonely and
insignificant all right so this next
piece
is really funny what they do is
so given clip you can build a classifier
so if you have the clip model that
connects images to text
what you can do is you feed one image
and then you give it a bunch of texts to
choose from
and whichever one it responds highest
with that's kind of
the class so if you provide the class
labels as text
you can build a zero shot classifier now
clip papers demonstrated that that works
well so here
they do this so they have this apple
right here
and the label is correctly apple
but if they just slap a sticker on it
that says ipod
the clip model will switch to ipod
and here yeah here is where i really
think that this model
it is a textual
model it responds even to rendered text
it responds
very heavily so here it responds to this
ipod
library like this ipod looks like
something i bought off craigslist last
week
um so you can see it works like almost
every single time you just slap a label
on it and that
tells me that we are still like that the
text is might be
too dominant in these models especially
you know this models they will connect
the text
with render text in the image and that
that's a very strong
signal for what's in the image right
this is only zero shot though if you
switch this to do linear probe so if you
actually train a linear probe on the
representation of clip then these
attacks don't work anymore
so this is going back again to sort of
the
old school deep learning approach where
you actually
train a classifier and once you train
it picks up on on other features and
then it doesn't work anymore
all right uh yeah so they they evaluate
this on a large scale they can't always
slap a label so they just fill
the image with render text and that
usually gets the classifier
confused fairly fairly well they also do
this with this
stroop test which you can do with humans
which is
fairly difficult if you do it at a high
speed and they discover
that the model basically pays no
attention
whatsoever to the color of
the word it pays much more attention to
what the word says
which is strange right because you you
think if i have a neural network
and um you know it basically needs to
to recognize the color here it needs to
filter out the white pixels but then
just average the pixels
it gets the correct answer that's so
easy right it simply averages
whereas to recognize that this says
green
is much more difficult but the model was
trained to connect
text and images images which often have
text
in them so it has learned to do ocr
basically
in the dolly video i claimed that dolly
has learned to do reverse ocr and people
correctly pointed out that that is more
aptly called
writing but i love reverse ocr
i'm going to call writing from now on
reverse ocr
so again this is evidence for the claim
that this is
mostly a textual model and now i want to
show you
what i found so if you're not in the
mood i have all this in a notion page
which i'll link
down below so i'll show you just some
interesting stuff sometimes it's
multimodal
sometimes it's not right so
we already were here we just clicked
around
but now i wanna kind of show you uh
the good stuff so this is a superman
neuron that i found
so it responds as you can see to symbols
of superman in the imagenet dataset
superman superman drawing superman
comics superman
uh spelled out rendered
and so on this is exactly kind of what
what the
the article was about right but now it's
superman not spider-man
um this i call the resting
bee face neuron so it responds to
people being slightly annoyed
yeah as you can see um
here this is trash bags so this responds
to
trash bags pretty cool right
so not any kind of bag right
specifically trash bags even if they are
not
black so there are a couple in there
that aren't necessarily
black there is even trash cans like dump
containers
right here that have no bag in sight yet
still that neuron response
this sorry about sorry about that
um yeah for some reason
you might wanna i don't know maybe have
something in your pockets
um yeah so so fairly cool oh there's a
tree
it's not always you know perfect but
these are the data set
examples that most excite that neuron
so you can also see the text isn't
always good though i think
i think if the text here isn't super
good
it might more be an effect of this
method to search text because text is of
course
not a continuous signal so it's fairly
hard to
search text that maximizes some
activation otherwise we could build
gans for text very easily which we
still can't um this one here
i've titled this strength and allah
and uh weightlifting which i'm
i'm aware this is not you know
iconography of
allah um however
so this is pretty cool as an image right
now if you look at what
in the data set what samples it responds
to
it's kind of all weightlifting it's
all weights so this is weight
weight and if you go down here
um to the other data set this is why i
called it
sort of allah because you have also
rendered names
like the the rendered allah you have the
quran you have
symbols of islam and if you go to the
text
that it searches goes like hammer
workout
prophet prophet zana in lumber iron gym
the brutal workout of god so
you know pretty cool neuron honestly and
you know that it that responds with this
i don't even i don't even know what
what that is is that is that hindu um
imagery
or buddhist imagery so cool
these are organs this is an organ neuron
i hope like you you can see that and it
responds to the render text
of control i don't know what to make of
it
also canal viral but
also to drawings you can see here a
drawing of a heart
for some reason also chins so it's not
always
super duper clear what a neuron does in
fact
most of these neurons you will find if
you go look at what
image net sound and these i believe
these are crops of image net samples not
entire pictures
so if you look at what um by the way
control and
ctrl if you look at what examples
most often it will be rendered text so
that the ima
no matter what neuron most neurons
actually pay attention to
rendered text rather than to images
the ones i've selected are the ones that
do
not but if you just go and click on some
random neuron we can actually try and
it's certainly going to
probably fail
this one looks pretty cool looks pretty
cool
actually that responds to printers yup
demonstration effect fails horribly
how about this one yeah so you can see
that
you know maybe you don't exactly know
what that is so you want to look at what
so here you see that it primarily
responds to the text
miss i guess m-i-s-s i miss you
mississippi
and so on um you know mississippi having
it twice in there
yeah that gotta respond pretty pretty
heavily and
most of the time you'll find something
like this that it responds very much to
the
rendered pieces of text in images
these are film spools and
so not only does it respond to film
spools but also
to things like director screening uh
popcorn um the
kind of movie theater labeling showing
hollywood cinemas there's also
entertainment
so you know the multi-modality again
this
this is a this is a phenomenon because
we introduce the text and it can connect
it on the text level
this is feather patterns and leaf
patterns
so even when it's in coffee you see
the feather and leaf patterns even when
it's
a drawing it can it will still respond
this one is strange
so this responds to things like
sparta and front
and troy but
so that it responds to rendered
front trojan spartans front
and it also has a lot of people doing
sort of squats
as you can see so um and and fighting
so this is kind of an iron so this is a
bit of
kind of a warrior neurons you can see oh
there's lots of
ah of course it's because of these
spartan
runs and all they're called like this
right these kind of sporting events
i see roman front side roman
roman so it connects the work out with
the spartan workout kind of division
and then it connects the trojan and so
on via
again via the text because it makes no
sense to connect like the vodka
and the and the weightlifting maybe i
don't know
so yeah i hope i hope you're fairly
convinced by now we're going to go a bit
faster now
uh because the video is already too long
but
this one here is the letter e so it's ee
it responds again to rendered text of e
this one here is cleaning so it responds
to cleaning products and cleaning things
this one here is frown so this is
frowning frowning frowning grumpy face
grumpy face um
lion lion
responding to lions render text of lions
team names called lions and so on
um fashion model
fashion model by the way the labels are
mine i just looked at them and decided
what they are
but you can see like there's a lot of
these kind of runway
shots here
baseball stadium so cool so these are
kind of top views of baseball stadium
but it responds a lot
to things saying park pnc park 18 t park
but also
kind of home team park lights
and and baseball dugouts and even
players i've seen some players
logos of teams baseball depictions of
actual baseballs immense
immensely cool here bride this is bride
you can see this is bride
this one what do you think
this one is navy so super cool that it
kind of kind of connects these ropes
with the emblems the the kind of um
your your tags so
and it connects connected to render text
saying navy
right so these are the crops of images
that it responds to
navy officials like officers navy
gravestones
yeah so cool this one okay
this for this i also had to look at sort
of the
um pictures here and the text going
along with it this is
hemp but it is also kind of goa patterns
it is also for some reason turn or urn
um it is also hendrix
so this isn't even jimi hendrix right
like this this is definitely connected
these goa
shirts um there is also there's pictures
of jimi hendrix
which i guess you can understand there
is also
um turn again
where is there's bob no this is bob
marley
sorry this spot morally um
yeah so so it connects these things uh
staircase
and here for some reason it also
responds to text rendered human
um and to staircases and
here i have i don't know why but there's
there's this thing which i'm not sure so
it has human in it but it is also
arranged like a staircase
so maybe that's why it responds extra
extra
uh yeah the disney neuron this is a
disney neuron
how cool is this how cool is this so
you can clearly see that that but then
it you know disney these are the
samples that it responds to simply
something saying disney
the mickey mouse ear the mini bow
um you know immensely
cool the the castle right the disney
castle
this is the hillary clinton neuron you
can see
this is hillary and
the images it responds to is
hillary hill pill paulie
hill hills so this is maybe it's more
like the lly the illy
neuron but it it does
pick out hillary clinton as well
yeah so imagenet of course is older than
at least one of hillary's campaigns i'm
not sure
this is god so i found this one this is
yeah god if you so the reconstruction
process is not very good at
generating text maybe because so they
have a lot of priors in that if you look
at the reconstruction
article um you can probably and they do
this in
in this article they reconstruct text
but it's still not super
clear maybe it has to do with the
architecture this here is blurry
it's just the concept of blurry so you
look at the images they're
kind of often blurry and if you look at
the text going along with it
uh it's all like blurry blurry blurry
blurry blurry blurry blurry blurry
cool like it's not even what's on the
image but
you can clearly see like this comes via
the description this is
hand drawn arrows or arrows in general
this looks like my videos now
right like this recognizes
arrows specifically uh you know kind of
colory arrows
this one what does it do this is
presenting a trophy you see this one
here in the middle
this is kind of so these are all you
know people presenting
some kind of thing holding some kind of
thing in their hand
showing it like fishermen or diplomas
um this one i was amazed by
this is a neuron responding to receding
hairlines
like it responds to receding hairlines
how cool is that how cool is that
uh this is traffic tent
and so on so it responds to tents and
traffics and
crowds of people this one
is um raised arms but
also pancakes so pancakes and raised
hands
for some reason there's a connection no
but i mean these these models they still
overload when they can this one how cool
is that
this is the google maps neuron these are
reconstructions these are not samples
these are reconstructed you can see it's
clearly it has
kind of the street labels and the pins
on it so this is a google google maps
like neuron what
so cool this one i call
nervous smile you can
maybe see that it's like huh
[Music]
here's elvis this is the elvis neuron
uh i know it sort of it also looks like
hendrix a bit
but the uh things it connects it to is
that's not elvis that's not elvis
kiss okay maybe it's not exactly elvis
maybe it's more like a pop star neuron
yeah maybe it's not elvis uh only elvis
billy elliot
this one is the flash right that's the
flash
and the cool thing is it responds to
images saying
flash
what okay beards
responds to beards generally beards
lots of beards kilts
kilts and bagpipes responds to guilt
kill some backpipes
rainy this is a neuron that responds to
things that are rainy rainy days so you
can see here
out the window it's raining rainy
windows
so cool this is flash and electricity
so you'll see like symbols these symbols
of these flashes but also kind of
electric hair curling up um
so
droplets how cool does that look like
that's just cool and the occasional
image net reconstruction thing where
there must be like half a dog face in
there
that is just trippy this one
is this one is escape
okay escape like look at that
like to connect these things
how long would you like without
contrastive learning
how well i guess if as long as you have
images and labels but still
king this is king so the depicted are
crowns but
response to renderings of king
this is nation how cool is that
nation response to country
country country oh it's country not
nation but still
this one responds to overweight men
there's a neuron that responds to over
faces of
of overweight men
um this one is wedding
this one is australia
and the cool thing here is that it
responds to rendered domain names of
australia like the top level domain of
australia
what mind blown
this is yawning or screaming
well i was like you know like
um here we have a same neuron for bees
and the simpsons bees and the simpsons
this is mussels and um seafood
and lastly spices
spices and other powdery
things you know
don't ask too many questions
all right so that was it from me for
today i have many more
that are linked in a notion description
somewhere go check it out please try out
this
i've not yet looked through all of them
there are so many there are literally
thousands of these units and this is
just one of the models they have
available
go look and share you know on our
discord
you know the best ones you find all
right that was it thanks for listening
bye